un mortal accidente que provocó la
intoxicación de decenas de personas un
grupo de mineros y de rescatistas fueron
víctimas de uno de los peores desastres
en los últimos años en rusia un incendio
tuvo lugar en una mina de carbón en la
región rusa de kémerovo en el occidente
de siberia algunos de los sobrevivientes
narraron los momentos previos al rescate
respiramos el gas y comenzamos a caminar
tanto como pudimos al principio ni
siquiera nos dimos cuenta de lo que
sucedió y olly moss un poco de gas eso
es todo después fuimos rescatados
estaba gateando y luego sentí que
alguien me agarró extendí mis brazos
hacia ellos no podían verme la
visibilidad era mala me agarraron y me
sacaron si no fuera por ellos estaríamos
muertos la mina de carbón se llenó de
humo por una explosión en el sistema de
ventilación
285 personas estaban al interior la
mayoría logró evacuar pero más de 50
perdieron la vida el presidente ruso
lamentó del hecho
las decisiones necesarias se toman en el
lugar esperamos que puedan salvar a la
mayor cantidad de personas posibles
cuando las personas pierden la vida es
siempre una gran tragedia
el comité de investigación regional dijo
que tres personas incluido el director
de la mina y su adjunto habían sido
arrestados bajo sospecha de violar las
reglas de seguridad industrial según
medios rusos la mina pagará a las
familias de las víctimas cerca de 27 mil
dólares como indemnización además de los
pagos que correspondan por ley